hey guys welcome to the third patreon q
a on this channel
where i'll be answering a bunch of
different questions you guys have sent
in
you can join my patreon from just two
dollars a month and get access to behind
the scenes content
as well as being able to submit a
different amount of questions depending
on
which tier you choose to join but with
that said let's get into this month's
questions which were sent in
by chronos gw and trey cash
the first question is what are your
thoughts on if shinzo was to take a race
ahead spot
in the fight against shigeraki do you
think shigeraki could break free of mind
control with
all for one's quirk similar to how deku
broke free of it
um yeah so to start with the second part
of that question
i do think shiguraki could break free of
it and there's a pretty simple reason
it's all about consistency
so back in the sports festival when deku
broke free
midoriya he specifically said that he
was the one who broke himself free
but it was because the vestiges gave him
a a second like they
they woke him up basically for a second
in that second it gave him an opening to
wake himself up
by this point in the manga we've seen
the similarities between
all for one and uh one for all and we
also got those panels with all might
being really secretive about the true
nature of one for all
not to mention deku pondering you know
the similarities between it
so clearly the quirks are almost linked
in a way especially with the whole
vestige world situation
in the most recent chapter we see all
for one literally in the vestige world
of one for all
and if brainwashing if brainwashing is
able to activate
the one floor vestiges then it stands to
reason that the same is true for sugar
and all for one um in recent chapters
you know uh
we saw that of one is literally inside
the quirk
and he can take control of shigaraki's
body that means that if sugi was
brainwashed by shinzo
for the sake of consistency all for one
should be able to
wake shiguraki up and allow him to break
free
and even if that wasn't the case um if
if shigaraki was brainwashed all for one
could just take over because
you know if you brainwash shigaraki
you're not brainwashing all for one so
he could then come out and take over the
body
so i think whichever way you cut it it's
just not going to work
at this stage against shiguraki to
answer the first part of your question
about shinzo taking a racehead spot
during the battle i know you were just
talking hypothetically but
yeah it wouldn't happen anyway because
shinzo still
is not on the hero course yet the
students are still in their first year
and shinzo isn't joining the hero course
until the second year
so it would be kind of irresponsible to
have a general study student
on the battlefield right now so yeah
he's not going to be involved for the
time being
although you guys know i love shinzo so
i hope he gets a chance to shine
later during this arc the second
question
is most overrated and underrated pro
hero
according to the charts um
okay so most underrated this one's easy
this is obviously izawa
i mean yeah okay so we don't know his
rating but we do know
that he's not in the top ten and he
should be he should be in the top 10.
um so what we know is that izawa is an
underground hero
he doesn't really get much spotlight so
obviously that would affect his ranking
and that's like a personal choice he's
made not to take the spotlight which is
fair enough
but um in my opinion he should be top 10
not just because of
his his insane skill but also his mental
uh his mental fortitude you know because
he he cut his own leg off
without even a second thought and
someone who fearlessly goes into battle
whenever his students are in danger
that's a true hero in my opinion you
know we saw it during the usj attack he
went
head to head with shigaraki and the nomu
during the oval arc he was helping deku
to fight overhaul
um the forest training camp he took on
derby single-handedly
obviously it wasn't the real derby but
it still had the same power as darby
and if you just tally it up you know the
amount of things that has always done at
this point
he's top 10 material so whatever
position he
is in it's it's too low it's too low um
but yeah that's what i had to say about
underrated now overrated
this is a bit difficult because um many
of the heroes in the
in the charts we actually haven't seen
them in action too much for example
wash and the nin the samurai guy so if
i'm just thinking about the heroes that
we've
truly seen in action i would say kamui
woods
would be the most overrated because he's
seventh on the pro hero
charts and not saying he's bad obviously
he's not a bad hero or anything like
that
but there's been a few moments when he's
been trying to do stuff and it's just
not worked out
um the one that comes to mind first is
episode one when he was trying to uh
restrain that villain and then mount
lady comes in
making her debut and she outshines him
so that was interesting and then
obviously during the battle at camino
uh he kind of captured everyone but then
they got transported away
so it's like he didn't really solve
anything there
and then obviously during the war arc he
um dabby just burned him up burned him
to a crisp
um now he did come back from that and he
did help time out lady to
gigantomachia but still he's taking too
many l's
for uh for my liking you know you can
take an l here and there but that's
i mean those are just one those are just
the ones that i remember there might be
more
more uh instances where he's uh where
he's you know
failed a bit so uh yeah i'm going to say
camuy woods
the third question is 1v1 could deku
beat any top 10 pro hero right now
if so who um how about the other big
names from 1a versus any top 10
in a 1v1 so regardless of how
powerful deku is i mean as a first year
student his level of skill could never
surpass
a top 10 pro hero i think that's just a
fact that said
because he has such overwhelming
strength on his side i do think he could
beat some of the top 10 heroes
especially now that he has multiple
quirks which he can
combine and use at the same time so yeah
he can do it
if we were to take deku at his best and
i would say his best is probably
right now when he's fighting shigeraki
you know he's using float black whip and
he's
giving 100 smashes so right now is the
best we've ever seen deku
and when you look at the top 10 yeah i'd
say
actually i say he he could
hypothetically
beat most of them at his best right now
um i think the ones he couldn't be
hawks probably hawks's insane speed and
his precision that he has
i think even with all of deku's strength
he might not be able to actually land a
hit and
get hawks even with black whip he might
not be able to grab him
i think that same statement is also true
for headshot as well he's very skillful
his quirk is good for like evading uh
evading attacks
uh and probably endeavor as well would
also defeat deku
not because he's stronger than deku in
any by any sense you know deku
has the power of all might and and we
all know how that went you know
endeavour could never surpass all might
but i think just with endeavors his vast
experience you know he
would probably find a way maybe it's by
wearing deku down you know letting deku
use all of his energy
and then beating him when he's tired or
perhaps grabbing deku when he's not
looking and then you know
doing prominence burn i think endeavour
could probably do it
but with the exception of those three
heroes i think deku's beating
at his best i think he could be um
everyone else in the top ten so that
includes ryukyu
wash uh crust you know because it's
almost an unfair
thing to say because he just has all
this power all these quirks you know he
is
he's got an unnatural advantage so um
yeah
it's not a fair fight but um but he
probably could beat them
in terms of the other big names from
class 1a versus any of the top 10
yeah i don't think this is happening so
the only reason i said like i said deku
has an unfair advantage
everyone else is is pretty normal i
guess with the exception of shoto
because he
kind of has two quirks there but um
yeah they're not quite at that level yet
but but you know what
back ago and todoroki specifically and
tokyo army i guess
insanely talented people so you know
they could be matching pro heroes easily
in their second year or third year um
but just just need a little they just
need something extra
that's all they just need something
extra and they can be doing that but
those are my thoughts for now
the last question came from uh chronos
gw and this was from a conversation he
and i were having uh on patreon
and essentially what he was asking was
when deku bit down on the force quack
activation
tentacles in the last chapter uh was
that like a foreshadowing potentially
or a glimpse at the fourth user's quirk
specifically he was talking about the
bite like is there some type of is it
kind of like a
a biting quirk or something like that i
think that's what he was trying to ask
anyway
um but basically my take on that is
deku biting force quite activation was
almost just
it was just his pure anger coming out
because we see that his right hand was
you know in action his left hand was in
action so it's like he's already using
both his hands
so what else can he use to destroy them
oh my mouth's right here let me bite
down on it too
it's kind of just like him trying to
destroy it no matter what because
he had just seen those tentacles impale
back ago you know he said his friend is
seriously injured because of this
so he was just doing anything he could
to destroy it
you guys know i think the fourth user's
quirk could be decay
but you know it could also be something
else and i've seen a few people theorize
in the in my comment section
that it could be forced quirk activation
you know that was the fourth user's
quirk
and if that's the case that would be
great foreshadowing because he's
biting down on force quick activation
while secretly you know he doesn't know
this but he's gonna inherit it later
so um obviously time will tell but uh
that would be good foreshadowing if it
was the case
that was all i had for this q a today
guys um if you want your question
answered then please
do uh check me out on patreon you know
submit your questions and they will be
answered
it can obviously be about my here
academia uh and also black clover one
punch man attack on titan
uh jojo's but only up to part five
because i haven't read part six yet
and until the next one peace out